whoa hello and welcome to this video had
a little bit of a glitch there with my
computer but no I'm on pin playing
Lemuria such a GM you from Latvia ego
Koba yanko he's very high rated I think
I had a game against him where him made
some blunder and its really curious how
many people and play this is this really
bad line okay and even a very high
player I rated player that this okay so
even Bishop e3 comes into consideration
as energy for age 7 is hanging so I
think I'll go for that wow I had still
very dangerous what he's doing here okay
so he just plays a quick stuff hopes for
the best let's see what is the point
there just 97 96 of this idea I guess
okay maybe cover d5 first and then see
what happens night bd7 I have an idea b5
may be attacking the sixth and planning
a three okay just cover just captures
interesting I can also just take with
them take with the pawn and now what's
interesting it's got Knight b6 maybe on
but then we should be five maybe Bishop
f4 here to attack d 696 Bishop b5 and
then see form should be good enough for
a small edge our came this interesting
now I cannot play I also was thinking
about Bishop b3 but then it's got pawn
to c4 this is this is not so great hmm
it's a bit awkward
it's a bit awkward IAM but i cannot play
Bishop b3 in this position hmm right now
has circa for him nie Dage for will keep
form let's move anyway maybe he could
have played that anyway Quincy 7 was
quickly played but I think he had this
one okay I'm just going out of this idea
hmm they somehow got away with this
quick and actually not so good play but
this is this opening is really not good
for black at all but I didn't manage to
get something real out of it
night eh 495 would be good if I can get
that in ok I will still do this he can
go go go a six but what is he doing here
this is the sustained juris for black
isn't that a bishop c8 maybe see if I
can get rid of one of those active rooks
here currently I control the e-file so
he has the rookie aid this he can
actually take
he wants to go to see 18 maybe take the
pawn when I get the push up to 286
looking at c5 threatening d6 now
one minute something is the issue and
the position is totally ok time learning
and the time is more problem than the
position no threat to the rook b7 takes
a pawn takes looks very dangerous i'm
gambling a bit here I could have taken
already but maybe I should have taken
let's take now maybe he's shooting for
the for the e porn yeah I don't see them
threat that the mole check this is the
threat oh that's nice that's a nice shot
now okay so he tricked me with queen bee
too I know it's a nice one didn't see it
okay so one trick wins flag besides yeah
take see it's got queen bee to check
before i think it was highly critical
for black let's see here this is how did
that work now he was mostly pressing a
lot on with the clock so and maybe i
should have taken immediately but he has
this yes is counter play against my king
the computer gives this position is
equal very likely with some Perpetual's
yeah here for example if i if i take
that immediately instead of this yeah
it's already winning a 95 is winning
that 93 is the thing
I have to probably take on a 70 m and
now this is some gather the engine gives
queen bee for shooting for a draw which
is probably realistic another idea is to
counter-attack like this and here I have
check this one to get to draw check this
is this is some kind of Perpetual back
they was very tough I spent lots of time
out outside in the opening because this
this line that he plays with b6 is just
bad for blackjack and white is better
here there's no doubt achieve he played
this like very quickly and putting me
under pressure and this is actually not
so clear the question is if I can
actually improve here already it says
something better even I e5 isn't but d5
looks normal and I can take with the C
porn maybe but if I do this I mean this
would be great if it just yeah I think
it has concrete problems let's say this
this and I thought some kind of see form
if it doesn't have some concrete tactic
than blacks position is pretty terrible
it just has a very bad kind of ninja we
should be no knee here but I thought
like c4 is probably on I have it maybe
I'm just better yeah yeah yeah yeah I'm
probably better oh no it's it's not easy
at all check the way I played this you
got this be five and then well you can
take this pawn of course but I didn't
want to do that especially not in the
Blitz game and rather 12 casual and this
is this is kind of playable so what he
played down be success has a very bad
reputation actually but he played one of
the better better tries for sure many
people play it much worse even going d 5
and so on this is better
okay here the computer actually gives
you five and sense why does it not
matter maybe this is the refutation
that's possible but what is black doing
it may be taking on f3 if you take moves
the night I just takes h7 I just take it
sound so this this check this is what
the computer gives it's kind of insane
to play this is black but it's not quite
sure if it is it is so terrible computer
gives white bag like a pawn plus one
yeah maybe this is the way to tackle
this b6 is really really bad but okay I
went d5 quite quickly and this is this
b5 move a strong if he it's not doing
this then I'm a lot better just
strategically because this Bishop is
dead it just looks at this is Pawn and
he has to immediately yeah break this
and suppose it was very good and this is
now ok for him so the critical moment
was I have to go e five instead of d5
and here he is kind of okay probably but
I make a mistake here this is a mistake
this move because because he has rookie
for which he missed this is the huge
angie carlson game this kind of trick I
saw it but he was just playing instant
moves all the time not thinking really
rookie for was capitalizing on my
blunder what I have to do it also from a
strategic point of view I have to play
this move so that after Knight b6 I can
place you fry this is this is important
that I can keep this cupboard I think
yeah I would still prefer white slightly
but it's nothing much okay this blunder
the piece which you didn't take and and
here I first of all made sure that I
didn't blunder stuff yeah this I again
liked we should h4 it's also good here
okay
and yeah I wasn't been surprised that he
allowed all this but ok I took it ya
hear I thought white must be better and
the computer whiz widest a lot better
here with Queenie six hmm Wow now this
is more or less winning actually oops
not this one shot he cannot take and
this pawn is just promoting wow I should
have cut I calculated that Wow if you
cannot take this is clearly good and
here I push him back yeah that's very
good for white takes no and this rock
ending is more or less winning for wine
hmm so that was a chance somewhere he I
mean I felt that there should be
something but ok I didn't want to spend
spend so long again Queenie 6 is strong
nighttime I didn't I saw this intending
d6 but he can't cover this yeah from
here he defended this very well it
shouldn't be in trouble ya later it
probably should have been a draw of it
he had this he found this nice trick
here with with 95 intending native 3
which I didn't didn't see at all we
added the trickier yeah very nice ok it
was an interesting game thanks for
watching